thanks Samantha there now as you just
heard Jeremy Corbyn telling Sky News
Britain should be doing more to help
ease Europe's migration crisis that
comes amid reports this morning the
Prime Minister is considering plans to
let thousands of unaccompanied migrant
children who have already arrived in
Europe into the UK among those children
will of course be many girls and young
women it's they who are the focus of a
new UN panel for women's economic
empowerment led by the International
Development Secretary Justine Greening
who joins me now and a very good morning
to you well morning let's talk about
about the broader point there about
trying to break the chains of dependency
for girls and women and going to have a
high panel of the United Nations some
people are going to say this is just
going to be another talking shop a
worthy talking shop but a talking shop
well I think it's going to achieve some
real concrete action we know that no
country can successfully develop if half
its population gets left behind and
that's the same for economies but around
the world in many countries women aren't
allowed to open a bank account they may
not be able to inherit assets they might
not be able to own land they might not
even be able to have a mobile so if
we're really going to unlock their
potential and see those economies take
off those things need to change in this
panel this group of experts that the
secretary-general has pulled together
it's it's yes I'm on that panel the UK
has put women and girls at the heart of
our development work but it also
includes Christine Lagarde of the IMF we
got Jim Kim who runs the world bank we
have business leaders on it civil
society people like Oxfam are
represented on it coming together to say
how can we change the term to tray so
that women can play their full role in
those economies as they grow around the
world okay so people are going to listen
to that and say wow I'm Foursquare
behind you of course I am but how in
reality do you make it happen let's you
know let's supply how would you apply
levers to the likes of Saudi Arabia
where culturally religiously politically
it's engrained within society that women
are second-class citizens well you're
right that it's not just about what
governments need to do so this is about
changing
is about businesses looking at how they
can bend the arc of their own
organizations to get more women into the
workplace it's about how attitudes as
you say need to change the social norms
that still in many many parts of the
world expect women to be in the home and
have no opportunity whatsoever to have a
livelihood or have a job if we're going
to really take a big step forward then
we need to get all of those things
changed together and it's not just in
the developing countries that we need to
see change of course here in the UK
we've been reforming our own laws to
make it easier for women to get back
into the workplace after they had
children to be able to share parental
leave and have more parental leave when
women have children and all those things
make it easier for women to play a full
roll so this this group will look at how
we can turbocharged that around the
world and how we can really change the
terms of trade for women in the world
people will want to know though
secretary state the practical
implementation I mean you've got quite a
pot of money in international
development to distribute four varieties
of causes around the world are you going
to and are you now saying well look i'm
not putting money into this because i
believe the united kingdom believes that
you have policies you have a society
which hasn't understood the role of
women in it well women participation in
our workforces never been higher which
is great but what we're doing is also
putting that desire to see women play a
full roll into our development work and
we're putting girls through school we've
been leading the charge on tackling FGM
and Link child marriage these are things
that keep girls out of school we're
putting investment into making sure that
women can have access to family planning
so that they can have more control over
when and how many children they have
we've been pioneering work in places
like Rwanda to allow land title be to be
put in place and many of the people
gaining from that and women we've been
around the world helping women get
access to credit to experience what we
now want to do is bring this into this
panel and see how we can work
collectively at the UN level it's an
illegal problem we're bringing positive
disk
nation to international aid essentially
we now have the gender equality at the
bill cash took through our own
Parliament which means we have to make
sure that improving the prospects of
girls and women is at the heart of every
single program that we do which i think
is right but this isn't just the right
thing to do it's the smart thing to do
if you look at a report by McKinsey that
came out towards the end of last year it
said if you just got every country to do
a better job to the best in its region
of getting women into livelihoods into
the workplace it would actually by 2025
lift global gdp by 12 trillion dollars
eleven percent so this is a huge leavin
not just in terms of pushing forward on
women's rights and women's empowerment
it's actually one of the biggest things
that we can also do to help safeguard
and protect the global economy and
growth going forward let me put you some
jeremy corbyn's points in that interview
he gave to my colleague fazal Islam our
political editor and may very well be
listening to this interview going well
we hear you saying all those those
wonderful things but look the points he
made about our direct contribution to
the migration crisis within Europe we're
not doing enough I thoroughly reject
that no country in Europe has done more
to help Syrian refugees the UK has been
there since day one worldwide were the
second biggest bilateral donors helping
refugees on the ground and our focus has
very much been on meeting refugees first
choice I've been out in the region many
times over the last few years i was out
just last week the refugees that i
talked to want to stay close to home
they want to stay in the region that
they're familiar with what we're doing
the week after next in london we're
holding a conference that isn't just
about raising more funding to help UN
agencies and ngos do the day-to-day
support for refugees that they need but
we're also galvanizing support for
Jordan and Lebanon to be able to help
create jobs for Refugees in those
countries to help make sure that every
single Syrian refugee child is in school
by the end of this coming academic year
it's in meeting these hopes and these
aspirations refugees
that we can help them do what they want
to do which is fundamentally to stay
close to home okay coming to Europe for
many of them is a last resort not a
first resort and we should be meeting
their first choice by helping them in
the region nevertheless nevertheless
there are going to be 20,000 people in
total coming to the UK from the castle
and you're thinking of loosening that
have been taking another 3,000 children
unaccompanied children can you confirm
that so you're right we have also played
our role place at a home here in Europe
and we said over the course of this
Parliament we will resettle 20,000
refugees we're going to do that in a
safe and measured on a managed way by
taking working with you and agencies
taking them directly from the region it
means we can focus on the most
vulnerable people including children who
otherwise would have no chance to make
the kind of journey that we've seen
other refugees make and of course we've
been helping on the ground in Europe too
so the UK has been working with UNHCR on
registering migrants as they arrive
we've been helping to provide blankets
medical support working with the Red
Cross for migrants when they're they've
been in countries like Greece and Italy
and also the Balkan so we are playing
around we are looking at whether we can
do more in relation resize 3,000
children power lines being drawn with
Canada transport absolutely in relation
to unaccompanied children because
children have always been from day one
at the heart of our response in the
region we know we've been the country
pioneering the known Lost Generation
initiative which is getting kids back
into school we've been working with
UNICEF on the ground in countries like
Jordan Lebanon to create safe places
where children can get reunited with
their family they get lost we've been
the country that's helping children get
trauma counseling so we've absolutely
put children at the center of our work
and we'll continue this specific round
ass we understand its variety of
charities in the main putting the the
pressure putting the recommendation to
the Prime Minister your counsel to mr.
camera would be listened very carefully
to them about these 3,000 children
that's exactly what we're doing and I
think that's the right thing so we've
steadily evolved our our approaches this
crisis as evolved we've been right
the forefront frankly of helping
children who've been affected by this
crisis and will continue to look at how
we can do that over the coming days and
weeks okay and just you mentioned there
about the work that the UK is is doing
to register people as they first arrived
within the European Union but of course
as you know it's been discussed by the
European Union more widely those rules
might have to change the so-called
Dublin settlement that you register in
the first you country that you come into
what would the UK's are 2 GB to that
while we've used the Dublin convention
very actively in returning people back
to your country where they could have
initially made an asylum claim so we
don't want to see that change and
actually I think what we've seen over
the last few months is this concept of
the Schengen area really not working in
practice it eats sharing many of the the
reasons why the UK in the first place
chose not to be part of it so clearly
this is part and parcel of why for us
immigration and and and free movement of
people is at the centre of what we're
trying to get renegotiated as a new UK
package by the the Prime Minister I
think what it's showing is that the kind
of concerns that the UK is raised in
this area are actually very valid and
increasingly being experienced and
shared by many countries across so you
don't think it's going to irritate some
of our EU partners as the Prime Minister
is in the heart the nitty-gritty of
these renegotiations I think what's
what's very clear is that this issue of
freedom of movement of people has to has
to be able to work practically and what
we're seeing is that the reality is that
the Schengen area isn't working
effectively for countries countries
themselves do it even in it are choosing
to put in place their own controls it's
really showing why we chose to be not in
showing in the first place and why that
for us certainly was the right decision
but in the end I think what is showing
is that the UK's concerns over how
Europe works are not only valid but
they're not only issues for you for us
their issues for the whole of the EU and
the sooner that we can reach a consensus
and on conclusion on how to work more
effectively the better okay Secretary of
State thank you very much deeper agency
just in greening in
National Development Secretary there